last question today is from Quinn Quinn
says what are you shocked about that
people actually buy on a regular basis
or ever ok DVDs I don't understand
buying DVDs at this point basically most
things are available online the things
that aren't I would probably get like if
I had to I would maybe try to get it
from a library where you can rent a DVD
I have about 50 DVDs from when I used to
have a DVD collection I've not added to
it for maybe eight or ten years and I
don't plan on buying any more DVDs and
to be perfectly honest I'm thinking
about getting rid of the ones I have I
don't really get building a DVD
collection at this point right I think
people just buy it because they like the
idea of having something tangible if
it's on your computer you can't really
see it you can't really show it off as
well they like the idea of collecting
something yep I think that that's
definitely a big part of it and that's
part of the vinyl movement people that
like getting vinyl with the cover art
and the lyrics and whatnot you can just
listen to whatever song you want on
Spotify I don't know the value of having
these physical records around but people
do like it oh absolutely and for my
answer I would say something like iced
coffee where you buy this thing every
day and you know three dollars a day it
doesn't seem like much but that adds up
to a thousand dollars over the course of
a year and for me it's not so much the
iced coffee but it's like the the
dessert Frappuccino type drinks that
have either the the sugar syrups and the
whipped cream and the all different
stuff going out and getting one of those
I know people who get those four or five
times a week and from a financial
perspective hey if you can afford it and
it doesn't bother you that that's gonna
be a 1-1 to $3,000 habit I guess
over the course of a year all power to
you that's fantastic I'm sure you're
saving a lot of money for retirement and
then using the excess to buy these
frappuccinos obviously but from a health
standpoint I also don't get it I feel
like people think oh I'm having a
Frappuccino it's the same as having a
cup of coffee or an espresso in the
morning yeah no that's not the case at
all you're basically having dessert
every single morning right and there's
the whole aspect of that it's caffeine
right so you're just buying into this
drug addiction everyday which is you
know not too harmful and and socially
acceptable
I mean cigarettes are phasing out at
this point but I mean there's a lot of
vices people are still on with regard to
purchasing
I still am surprised when people buy
those extra services like the I don't
they don't call it rustproofing anymore
I know that it's like satirical almost
to say you know we're gonna do you want
the extra rust rust proofing but there
is some treatment of the paint that is
offered and it was offered to me not
with my most recent lease but I think
the previous one and my answer was are
you telling me that unless I pay extra
to treat the paint the the factory paint
on the car isn't even good enough to
last three years and usually the finance
manager at that point will say well no
it's not that I'm saying that but it's
that you know because of the environment
and if you park under a tree and the SAP
and acid rain and hail whatever yeah I'm
not buying the paint protection on the
vehicle or whatever else it is that's
being offered I do
get surprised when people buy some of
those things and also I get surprised
when people buy the extra warranty on a
new car that comes with a five year
warranty and very often it's not even
extending the warranty very often it's
the warrant he doesn't the the
manufacturer warranty doesn't cover
everything so we sell an extra warranty
that really does and and typically when
you do the math on what you're paying
and what extra coverage you get it
doesn't really make sense and this is
coming from someone who made 40 percent
of my income when I worked at Circuit
City from selling warranties I can
assure you over the long term the
warranty is not meant to save you money
the math of it is that it's usually
cheaper over the very long term to sort
of self insure now with health insurance
which is effectively sort of a warranty
on your health the potential cost of
expensive medical treatment is so high
that only the very richest Americans
would say hey you know what if I end up
needing to spend a quarter of a million
dollars on medical treatment I can
afford it doesn't really make sense
right you this does make sense for most
people to have health insurance I've
never bought a warranty on any
electronics period right so the eight
laptops I've had since I was fourteen
every single time I could have spent
$200 on a warranty or five bucks a month
on my cell phone or whatever
I never have a few years ago I dropped
my phone
it broke I had to go out and spend 250
bucks for a new screen the 250 bucks was
way less than had I been paying
thousands of dollars in warranties over
a very long period of time so I remain
convinced that on most as I punch my mic
there on most electronics buying
warranties doesn't really make sense
makes sense yeah electronics or cars I
mean I guess they figure if someone's
gonna spend forty thousand dollars on a
car fifty thousand dollars in a car they
can probably squeeze a few extra hundred
dollars out of them on something like a
warranty yeah although my point would be
if you're spending forty or fifty
thousand dollars on a car it should
probably come with a good enough
warranty that you don't have to pay
extra that that's my I know that that's
crazy right that's not it doesn't make
sense to a lot of car manufacturers but
that's sort of my view on it okay those
are some of my thoughts on what I'm
always surprised at people spending
money on send me some of yours and we'll
talk about this more on the bonus show
if we get some good feedback from people
speaking of which we've got a great
bonus show for you today you can sign up
and get instant access at david
pakman.com slash membership and we do
have the 2017 david pakman show calendar
comic book coloring book available with
original artwork from david pakman show
viewer Dan Burke you can get the
calendar for free with a yearly
membership at david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 check it out